jetzt geht es direkt weiter hier im
Plenum nämlich mit einer aktuellen
Stunde zur china-strategie der
Bundesregierung und wir hören den ersten
Redner Johann badepol für die CDU und
Entscheidung dieses Bundestages die
Unionsfraktion ist grundsätzlich gewählt
in den Fragen der außen der
Sicherheitspolitik auch in den großen
Fragen der Außenwirtschaftspolitik diese
Bundesregierung zu unterstützen
voraussetzung dafür ist allerdings das
ist eine erkennbare
kohärente Politik der Bundesregierung
gibt und die stellen wir nachdem wir es
mittlerweile schon das Verhältnis zu
Frankreich auf einem Tiefstand ist
nachdem mittlerweile viele
Bündnispartner in der NATO insbesondere
im Osten Zweifel an der Verlässlichkeit
Deutschlands haben diese Kohärenz diese
Klarheit in der Politik stellen wir
mittlerweile auch im Bereich oder im
Verhältnis zur Volksrepublik China nicht
mehr fest
dabei ist natürlich China-Politik von
herausragender Bedeutung und es ist
unstreitig das ist eine der größten
Herausforderungen für die deutsche und
die europäische Politik ist dem gerecht
zu werden als Staat mit dem wir
einerseits
den wir einerseits das größten
Handelspartner haben der aber
andererseits ganz eindeutig das Ziel
formuliert hat und das ist jetzt auf den
Parteikongress noch einmal geschehen die
stärkste politische wirtschaftliche und
bestimmende Nationen auf dieser Erde zu
werden diesem Zweck sind dem Regime in
China alle Mittel heilig
Menschenrechtsverletzungen millionenfach
durch Unterdrückung der Uiguren der
Bruch internationalen Rechts wie wir
gesehen haben in den Vereinbarungen die
Vereinbarung mit dem Vereinigten
Königreich betreffend Hongkong wird
nicht eingehalten künstliche Inseln
werden gegründet ein die de
factoerrichtung eines diktatorischen
Regimes das am Ende nur noch von einer
Person abhängig ist nachdem Präsident
Jeep sich dort jetzt hat erneut wählen
lassen das erste Mal seit Mao Zedong
eine so starke Stellung und was passiert
in dieser Situation was brauchen wir in
dieser Situation eine Zerstrittenheit
der Bundesregierung eine Zerstrittenheit
der koalitionsfraktion und ein
Bundeskanzler dem es bei seiner Reise
nach Peking schlicht und ergreifend
darum sagen zu können ich bin erster ich
bin der erste der diesem Diktator die
Hand geschüttelt hat nach diesem
Kongress das ist keine China-Politik die
den Ansprüchen Deutschlands an eine
europäisch abgestimmte eine
transatlantisch abgestimmte
China-Politik gerecht wird meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
es ist überhaupt gar nicht erkennbar was
ihre gemeinsame Position ist wir haben
doch alle gemeinsam in der Europäischen
Union mittlerweile eine gemeinsame
Position entwickelt den wir festgestellt
haben ja in Fragen des Klimaschutzes auf
der Bekämpfung einer kovid-krise wollen
wir versuchen auch Sachen gemeinsam mit
China zu regeln Ja das ist notwendig das
ist auch und vermeidbar Chinas in
manchen Bereichen Wettbewerber Maschine
ist systemischer Rivale China akzeptiert
gemeinsam mit Russland überhaupt nicht
die internationale Ordnung sondern will
sie zerstörend greift sie an und will
eine eigene sinozentrische Ordnung
aufstellen meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren zu so etwas erwarten wir eine
Politik der Bundesregierung die Klarheit
hat und dem entgegentritt und unser
internationales Regelwerk verteidigt
das erleben wir
wir erleben ein Bundeskanzler der
dorthin reist und schlicht bekannt gibt
dass China auch gegen einen Atomkrieg
sei das ist längst bekannt wir erleben
eine bundesaußenministerin die den
Zeitpunkt und wohl auch die Reise an
sich aus dem Ausland kritisiert ist
eigentlich gute Sitte in Deutschland das
noch nicht mehr die Opposition das macht
sie erlauben sich derartige zenkereien
innerhalb der Regierung ist es im Grunde
zum außenpolitischen fremdschemen was
sie hier
abliefern das ist keine kohärente
Politik und es gibt keinen an keinen
Versuch des Bundeskanzlers bei diesem
bei diesem Besuch in Peking China einmal
darauf aufmerksam zu machen was doch
unsere gemeinsame europäische Position
ist das nämlich Präsident Chi
aufgefordert ist Putin zu stoppen er
hätte als klare Signal überbringen
müssen das Peking diesen Krie nicht
weiter dulden oder auch noch fördern
darf das ist unterlassen worden oder
sein schwerer schwerer außenpolitischer
Fehler den der Bundeskanzler unternommen
hat und dass das ohne den französischen
Staatspräsidenten der angeboten hatte
gemeinsam zu reisen geschehen ist zeigt
einmal mehr der Bundeskanzler ist
offensichtlich überfordert eine
europäische abgestimmte Politik zu
machen die deutsch-französische Achse am
Leben zu erhalten ist eine Lebensader
und Europäischen Union und dafür zu
sorgen dass wir diesem Regime
geschlossen entgegentreten herzlichen
Dank die cdu/csu-fraktion hat diese
aktuelle Stunde beantragt rund um das
Thema neue China Strategie ja der
Bundeskanzler war zum Antrittsbesuch in
Peking auch andere Dinge rund um China
sind gesprächswertig ein Hafen Deal da
hat die Bundesregierung ja noch
ermöglicht mit dem chinesischen Konzern
cosco andere China die es hier sind
jetzt gerade gestern von der
Bundesregierung gestoppt worden da geht
es um Geschäfte chinesischer Investoren
mit deutschen Unternehmen einmal mit was
die chipsfertigung eines Dortmunder
Unternehmens anbelangt und noch ein
anderes Unternehmen in Bayern was im
Bereich
halbleiteranlagenindustrie tätig ist
also das wird sicher hier noch eine
Rolle spielen in dieser aktuellen Stunde
spricht jetzt Michael Müller für die SPD
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
nicht erst seit dem russischen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine wissen
wir wie problematisch wirtschaftliche
Abhängigkeiten für uns sind in Bezug auf
Energie sehen wir das jetzt natürlich
ganz deutlich aber auch während der
corona-pandemie ist uns das deutlich
gewordenen Bezug auf medizinisches auf
gesundheitsausstattung die wir eben aus
China importieren mussten und auch dort
haben wir schon Abhängigkeiten erlebt es
kann also kein weiter so gehen wir
lernen aus dieser internationalen
Situation dass diese Situation
aufgegeben werden muss dass wir
Abhängigkeiten reduzieren müssen es kann
Mutter so geben auch weil diese China
dass wir jetzt erleben unter
Staatspräsident Ski ein ganz anderes ist
als das China von vor 10 oder 15 Jahren
es hat sich stark in und außenpolitisch
verändert wir müssen tatsächlich unsere
liefer- und Versorgungsketten
diversifizieren wir müssen neue
Handelsbeziehungen aufbauen neue
Partnerschaften auch suchen wir sind
dabei das im Rahmen einer
china-strategie zu formulieren das eint
uns dass wir einen neuen Anspruch an
unsere Beziehung zu China formulieren
und in dieser Phase weist der
Bundeskanzler nach China um auch diese
Position zu vertreten und zum
wiederholten Mal heute hier in der
Aktuellen Stunde so wie in den letzten
Tagen öffentlich kritisiert Ihnen die
Union dafür warum eigentlich was das
falsch gewesen an dieser Reise der
Zeitpunkt wird kritisiert dass der
Bundeskanzler jetzt nach China gefahren
ist was wäre eigentlich liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in zwei Wochen
oder in zwei Monaten anders welche
andere Situation hätten wir
außenpolitisch welche andere Situation
hätte es in China gegeben so richtig wie
eine Reise in zwei Monaten gewesen wäre
so richtig war sie jetzt dass der
Bundeskanzler dorthin gefahren ist meine
Damen und Herren und dass er unsere
Position deutlich gemacht hat und er hat
es zum Beispiel im Bereich der
Menschenrechtsfragen viel deutlicher
gemacht als es in den letzten 16 Jahren
durch Bundeskanzlerin Merkel passiert
ist ja sie ja natürlich es ist deutlich
formuliert worden in diversen
Gesprächssituationen welche
Anforderungen wir haben wo
Menschenrechtsverletzung vorliegen was
wir von der chinesischen Seite erwarten
und ich sage hier auch ganz deutlich wir
brauchen an dieser Stelle von der Union
auch kein Nachhilfeunterricht das
lieferkettengesetz das genau das Thema
der Menschenrechte themaisiert ist gegen
die Blockade der Union durchgesetzt
worden dort Anfang nächsten Jahres
umgesetzt und formuliert im Übrigen
nicht nur in Richtung China sondern
weltweit
Anforderung beim Thema Menschenrechte es
gibt noch es gibt noch einen Unterschied
bevor Bundeskanzler Scholz nach China
gefahren ist hat er andere wichtige
Auslandsreisen unternommen anders als
Frau Merkel in den vergangenen 16 Jahren
die ihre ersten großen Asien reisen
immer nach China gemacht hat ist Olaf
Scholz als allererstes nach Japan
Gefahren ein wichtiges Signal das nicht
nur von Japan und China sondern von
vielen Partnern möglichen neuen Partnern
im asiatischen Raum sehr sensibel
aufgenommen wurde dass der Bundeskanzler
hier deutlich macht wir sehen andere
Ansprechpartner wir wollen neue
Partnerschaften eingehen oder alte
bestehende Partnerschaften vertiefen und
ausbauen eben jenseits von China und zum
dritten meine Damen und Herren
ja durch diesen Besuch und von oder
Schulz ist es möglich gewesen dass der
chinesische Staatschef das erste Mal
sich in aller Klarheit abgegrenzt hat
von Russland und in aller Klarheit
deutlich gemacht hat auch nur die das
geringste Spiel mit der Möglichkeit
eines atomaren Konflikts wird von China
verurteilt und isoliert Russland immer
mehr und eine weitere Eskalation würde
Chemie China eindeutig verurteilen in
diesem Konflikt meine Damen und Herren
ja das ist eine neue Qualität sie sagen
dass es alles altbekannt dass wir aber
dieser Äußerung des chinesischen
Staatschefs so in aller Klarheit erleben
konnten ist auch dem Umstand geschuldet
das Olaf Scholz in aller Klarheit unsere
und die europäische
Situation dort in China eben auch
vertreten hat und es so auch zu dieser
gemeinsamen Äußerung mit China gekommen
ist meine Damen und Herren ja wir
klicken unsere Verhältnisse unser
Verhältnis zu China auf eine neue Basis
stellen auch die kritische Infrastruktur
was können wir überhaupt noch
anhandelsbeziehungen eingehen und was
nicht wird jetzt erstmalig formuliert
Kriterien für die kritische
Infrastruktur und weitere
Handelsbeziehungen und
Geschäftsbeziehungen werden jetzt
erstmalig festgehalten wir werden eine
neutrale Basis haben um zu sehen auf
welcher Grundlage wir mit dem Partner
China weiter Handel betreiben können und
Geschäftsbeziehungen eingehen können
meine Damen und Herren China wird kein
einfacher Partner bleiben aber er wird
ein wichtiger Partner sein auch um
weitere wichtige globale Fragen
anzugeben wenn wir an die Klimakrise
denken an Hunger an not an Flucht an
atomares Wettrüsten China wird ein
wichtiger Gesprächspartner bleiben wo
wir aber auf Grundlage unserer China
stattgegeben
Selbstbewusstsein unserer Anforderung an
diese Partnerschaft formulieren vielen
Dank
der Besuch von Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
durchaus eine umstrittene Reise auch die
Zeitpunkt in der Reise rein nur elf
Stunden war er übrigens da auch wegen
strenger corona-maßnahmen
ich frage einmalig ist noch ein Mitglied
des Hauses anwesend dass seine Stimme
nicht abgegeben hat
herzlichen Glückwunsch
warum sind so viele jetzt unterwegs
also es laufen ja im Hintergrund immer
noch die Wahlgänge die einige Zeit
geöffnet bleiben
Wahlgänge zu einem Stellvertreterposten
bundestagsvizeposten wo die AFD einen
neuen Kandidaten ins Rennen schickt und
auch parlamentarisches Kontrollgremium
wird gewählt übrigens auch einen
Mitglied für den Beirat für das
Sondervermögen 100 Milliarden Euro
Sondervermögen was die Bundeswehr
anbelangt da hat die Linke und die AFD
noch keinen Kandidaten die Linke schickt
hier gesehene Lötsch ins Rennen die das
letzte Mal übrigens wieder nur drei
Stimmen fehlten
und genau und dabei geht es um dieses
Gremium also diese Abstimmung laufen im
Hintergrund also ich war gerade bei der
Reise von Olaf Scholze durchaus strittig
war elf Stunden hat sie gedauert
kritisiert wurde ja beispielsweise
Johann badepool hat es auch schon
angesprochen dass der Kanzler dem
Staats- und parteiche Ski als erster
westlicher Regierungschef unmittelbar
nach dem Ausbau seiner macht ja seine
Aufwartung gemacht hatte vor der Reise
allerdings hatte Olaf Scholz schon
angekündigt eine neue Justierung der
deutschen China Politik darauf hatte
sich die Ampelkoalition übrigens ja auch
schon in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag
verständigt daran wird bei gerade noch
gearbeitet jetzt also in dieser
aktuellen Stunde weiter mit Peter
bistron für die AFD
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen die CDU hat
jetzt plötzlich den Begriff Souveränität
entdeckt und fühlt die deutsche
Souveränität bedroht durch China ganz
ehrlich ich frag mich was ist der Anlass
dazu wir haben als Deutschland seit 50
Jahren beste Beziehungen zu China es war
der deutsche Außenminister Walter
Schilder als erster nach China gereist
ist noch ein Jahr vor Kissinger und
diplomatische Beziehungen mit China
aufgenommen hat davon haben wir
profitiert daran hat sich nichts
geändert außer dass die USA jetzt China
zu ihrem Feind erkoren haben ja und sie
gehen jetzt im Schlepptau der Amerikaner
und möchten hier eine Bedrohung China
als Bedrohung aufbauen
dazu erwarten wohl und sie haben hier
sogar jetzt dazwischen geschrieben ja
Hamburg kritische Infrastruktur wie
lächerlich ist dieses Argument da will
China nicht mal 25 Prozent an einem
Terminal nicht mal an einem Hafen an
einem Terminal kaufen und sie bauschen
das auf zu einer Bedrohung des
Souveränität Deutschlands ich bitte Sie
cos
Co hat von 100% in Griechenland über
Niederlande Belgien Spanien in Spanien
haben die sogar über 51%, ist dies
Souveränität dieser Länder irgendwie
bedroht natürlich nicht das ist eine
völliger Mumpitz was sie hier erzählt
haben
wir sind wir sind wir sind eine
Exportnation wir produzieren hier Güter
die exportieren wir in die ganze Welt
wie es brauchen auch waren die wir
importieren China ist unser größter
Handelspartner das wissen sie genauso
wie wir alle und unsere deutschen Firmen
machen dasselbe Hapag Lloyd hat zehn
Beteiligungen an Häfen in der ganzen
Welt Fraport an zehn Flughäfen in der
ganzen Welt und in China in Shanghai
sogar 50%. wir brauchen den Handel wir
brauchen den Warenaustausch und für das
was wir in für uns in Ausland in
Anspruch nehmen müssen wir das müssen
wir natürlich auch unseren Partnern hier
in Deutschland ermöglichen
und übrigens das sind ihre CDU und
csu-kollegen die sich über Investitionen
von China in Deutschland freuen das ist
hier ihr Hendrik wüst CDU
Ministerpräsidentin in
Nordrhein-Westfalen der die
Zusammenarbeit im Rahmen der neuen
Seidenstraße lobt das ist ihr
CSU-Kollege der KUKA gerade die
Investition bei KUKA gelobt habt und
wenn Sie sich anschauen wie sind die
Ergebnisse KUKA hat letztes Jahr das
zweitbeste Ergebnis seiner ganzen
Firmengeschichte gefeiert das ist das
Ergebnis der guten Zusammenarbeit
zwischen China und Deutschland
und
wissen Sie
wenn wir bei Duisburg bleiben da ist
jetzt ein
schienentterminal was das so hoch gelobt
wird und das ist ein Knotenpunkt
in der Seitenstraße und darum beneiden
uns andere Länder da ist ein ganz großer
Konkurrenz die Chinesen haben 100
Milliarden die wollen 100 Milliarden
Dollar schon investiert in die ganze
Seitenstraßen Infrastruktur und die
Polen hätten das gerne und die sagen
sehr wir möchten dieser Knotenpunkt in
Polen haben in Deutschland ist die
Infrastruktur die Bahninfrastruktur
nämlich schon so mache oder dass da kein
sicherer Transport möglich ist und das
lieber Herr Dr wagenpol das ist das für
Schulden ihrer cdu-kollegen ihrer
Verkehrsminister von Wissmann bis an die
scheuer von der CSU
und das beste Beispiel ist der
Transrapid eine deutsche
Spitzentechnologie die wir hier aufbauen
wollten in Deutschland die ihre Kollegen
eben bis man und
der bayerische Ministerpräsident
naja es ist 2008 war das ja 2008 ja wo
sie das beerdigt haben stattdessen wurde
die Technologie nach China verkauft der
Transrapid fährt jetzt in Shanghai und
der Nachfolger zu gebaut von den
Chinesen der fährt 620 km/h pro Stunde
damit könnten wir hier alle von München
nach Berlin können wir in einer Stunde
fahren und müssen uns nicht mit den
ständigen Verspätungen der Deutschen
waren Grundlagen oder mit dem Desaster
hier Flughafen
Berlin-Brandenburg ja
also liebe Kollegen die größte Bedrohung
für Deutschland sind nicht die Chinesen
die größte Bedrohung für Deutschland
sind sie die Politiker die dieses Land
gegen die Wand gefahren haben in den
letzten Jahren dankeschön
vielen Dank Herr
[Applaus]
nächste Rednerin ist die Kollegin
anjaschka Brugger Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in den letzten
Jahren mussten wir alle feststellen
unsere Demokratie unsere Sicherheit
unsere Wirtschaft ja unsere Art und
Weise zu leben all das ist nicht
selbstverständlich und all das ist auch
nicht unverletzlich die Welt ist in den
letzten Jahren rauerkrisenhafter und
unfriedlicher geworden und eine Politik
die das nicht wahrhaben will sie ist
nicht nur naiv sondern gefährlich und
das erleben wir in diesen Tagen
besonders deutlich wenn Staaten auch in
gut gemeintem Interesse ursprünglich
miteinander in vielfältigen Beziehungen
verflochten sind
und ein Staat davon dann aber macht
Erwerb und Ideologie über die
Kooperation zu beiderseitigem Vorteil
stellt dann wird eben aus Verpflichtung
schnell eine Abhängigkeit die zu
Verwundbarkeit werden kann und im
Ernstfall nicht nur finanziell ziemlich
teuer werden kann
jahrelange Anzeichen ja Alarmsignale von
Putins Russland zu ignorieren weil man
sie nicht wahrhaben wollte oder weil ein
billiges Geschäft wichtiger war als
unsere Werte und unsere echten
Interessen das war mehr als fahrlässig
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ein Staat
der nicht in seiner Sicherheit gefährdet
ist zugleich aber immens militärisch
aufrüstet und seine Nachbarn bedroht der
tut das in der Regel nicht mit einem
friedlichen Ziel wohin das im Fall von
Putins Russland geführt hat ist
eigentlich auch nicht erst am 24 Februar
mit dem brutalen Überfall auf die
Ukraine offenbar geworden diese Ignoranz
und diese Naivität auch die Fehler der
alten deutschen russland-politik sie
müssen uns allen eine deutliche Lehre
sein
und so wenig wir uns das wünschen mögen
so sehr müssen wir doch auch anerkennen
dass sich die Politik Chinas gerade in
den letzten Jahren rapide verändert hat
China wird immer mehr zu Diktatur sitzt
immer stärker auf Nationalismus die
chinesische Führung zeigt ihr wahres
Gesicht bei den krassen
Menschenrechtsverletzungen gegenüber den
uigurinnen und in der autokratischen
wildkör gegenüber kritischen Stimmen im
eigenen Land bei der Eskalation im
Südchinesischen Meer und den immer
aggressiver werdenden militärischen
Drohungen gegenüber den Menschen in
Taiwan sie zeigt das angesichts der
Situation in Tibet und in Hongkong und
all die Menschen die dort und in China
unter der Verletzung ihrer Freiheit und
ihrer Rechte leiden sie haben unsere
Aufmerksamkeit sie haben unsere
Solidarität verdient nicht nur in Worten
sondern auch in Taten
[Applaus]
meine Damen und Herren der Charakter der
chinesischen Führung zeigt sich aber
auch beim wiederholten Schulterschluss
mit dem Kriegsverbrecher Putin bei
jüngung beim jüngsten Versuch kann er
das Demokratie durch Korruption und
Einflussnahme zu schwächen und den
harschen Sanktionen gegenüber Litauen in
der Politik gegenüber den Staaten in
Afrika wo vermeintlich hilfreiche
Investitions schnell zum Hebel für
chinesische Machtinteressen werden all
diese Entwicklung die können wir weder
ignorieren noch dürfen wir sie
kleinreden
und wenn China seine Politik verändert
dann kann und darf unsere Politik nicht
die alte bleiben das Außenministerin
Werbung eine neue china-strategie
schreibt die Schluss macht mit Merkel
Business es usual ist daher Ausdruck von
kluger weitzicht und lieber Kollege
badeful ich habe mich schon gewundert es
wäre gut wenn wir heute noch mal auch
selbstkritisch auf die Fehler der
Vergangenheit geschaut werden ich kann
mich noch gut daran erinnern wo
Bundeskanzlerin Merkel in der Frage
Huawei und Telekommunikation Stand oder
wie lange sie schon auch gegen
zahlreiche Widerstände am
Investitionsabkommen mit China
festgehalten hat sie haben diese Chance
hier an der Stelle verpasst
natürlich können und wollen wir nicht
alle Verbindungen Kappen man muss auch
weiterreden in Zeiten von
Systemkonkurrenz wenn fundamentale
Krisen wie die Klimakatastrophe die
Menschen in China wie in Deutschland
gleichermaßen bedrohen oder auch wenn
ein skrupelloser Kriegsverbrecher mit
nuklearschlägen dem ultimativen
Tabubruch im Krieg droht Bundeskanzler
Scholz hat bei seiner Reise erklärt dass
China und Deutschland sich einig sein
das russische Droge werden mit
Atomwaffen nicht akzeptabel sind als
Mitglied im vm-sicherheitsrat muss China
diesen Worten auch Taten folgen lassen
und seinen Einfluss auf Wladimir Putin
geltend machen
und auch wenn wir in komplizierten
Beziehungen zueinander bleiben in
kritischen und sensiblen Bereichen
unsere Staates unserer Infrastruktur
unser Wirtschaft müssen wir uns besser
schützen das fängt mit einem besseren
europäischen Monitoring von Lieferketten
an das bedeutet eben auch die
Untersagung von Investitionen wie es die
Bundesregierung gestern richtigerweise
getan hat es kann aber auch die
Verschärfung von Gesetzen zum Schutz der
kritischen Infrastruktur beinhalten
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck hat es
gestern treffend auf den Punkt gebracht
eine offene Marktwirtschaft ist keine
naive Marktwirtschaft
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Menschenrechte sind nicht westliche
Werte und keine Naivität es sind
universelle Rechte und Regeln die sich
die Weltgemeinschaft gegeben hat in
dieser Frage bin ich Außenministerin
bärbock für ihre klare Haltung dankbar
und ebenso Bundeskanzler Scholz für das
jüngste Treffen mit den
menschenrechtsanwälten für
Menschenrechte einzutreten ist Ausdruck
unserer Überzeugung und unser
grundlegendes Interesse sie gehören ins
Zentrum unserer neuen china-strategie
denn sie bilden das Rückgrat unserer
Außenpolitik
anschließend an Agnieszka Brugger die ja
Robert Habeck gestern von gestern
zitiert hat hat Robert Habeck auch
gesagt China sei und solle
Handelspartner bleiben aber man sehe ein
bewusstes strategisches Vorgehen gerade
im Bereich von Halbleitern und
mikrochipfertigung und deswegen wie
gesagt gab es gestern gerade den Stopp
in zwei Fällen von geplanten Geschäften
chinesischer Investoren bei deutschen
Unternehmen
abgegebene Stimmkarten 690 mit ja haben
gestimmt 36 mit Nein haben bestimmt 654
Enthaltungen keine der Antrag ist damit
abgelehnt
das war noch der Nachtrag der wurde
abgestimmt im Hintergrund und ausgezählt
über einen Antrag der Linksfraktion zur
Einführung einer Vermögensabgabe ja
Linksfraktion ist das Stichwort jetzt
spricht hier in der Aktuellen Stunde die
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Linken Amira
Mohammed Ali
es leben Indien das einwohnerreichste
Land der Welt es ist die zweitgrößte
Volkswirtschaft Mitglied des un
Sicherheitsrates und sowohl mit uns als
eben auch mit Russland wirtschaftlich
eng verbunden klar ist darum wer Druck
auf Moskau ausüben will den furchtbaren
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine zu
beenden der muss Peking ins Boot holen
und darum war es auch richtig das
Kanzler Scholz nach China gereisten ich
frag mich warum erst jetzt das hätte
früher geschehen müssen aber schlimmer
noch als dieses Zögern ist dass ihre
Außenministerin Annalena baerbock bisher
noch gar nicht in China war und ihr
diplomatischer Beitrag beschränkt sich
auf fragwürdige Provokation vor einer
Woche bezahlte sich China als
systemischen Rivalen ja was das denn
jemand der politische Beitrag der
Chefdiplomat in Deutschland sind dieser
Krise besteht allen Ernstes darin sich
in kalter Kriegsrhetorik zu ergehen das
unverantwortlich
und ja es stimmt ja es stimmt China ist
kein demokratischer Staat es stimmt dass
dort gravierende
Menschenrechtsverletzungen einer
Tagesordnung sind Minderheiten werden
systematisch unterdrückt die
Meinungsfreiheit ist erheblich
beschnitten für Millionen Menschen gibt
es keinen Arbeitsschutz oder
Arbeitnehmerrechte das ist alles absolut
inakzeptabel aber
das ist leider alles auch absolut nichts
neues das ist seit Jahren so nennen wir
es beim Namen der Grund warum die
Menschenrechtsverletzungen in China
jetzt so ein Thema sind ist der Umstand
dass ich die Konkurrenzsituation
zwischen den USA und China verschärft
hat in Bezug auf die Frage wer Weltmacht
Nummer eins ist bzw wird das ist die
Wahrheit und wer glaubt dass die
menschenrechtlage in China sich dadurch
verbessert dass Europa sich gegen China
abschottet ist einfach auf dem Holzweg
das ist keine menschenrechtsbasierte
Außenpolitik das ist eine
Instrumentalisierung von Menschenrechten
und das geht nicht
und was
was ist das Ergebnis dieser beginnenden
Abschottungspolitik China rückt immer
näher an Russland heran die Gefahr eines
mächtigen Blockes bestehen aus Russland
China Indien und im Iran der die EU und
die USA wirtschaftlich und geopolitisch
an den Rand drängen kann diese Gefahr
wächst und diese Entwicklung darf man
doch nicht auch noch befördern
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Welt
die Welt ist nicht mehr so dass die
westlichen Staaten Sie sich einfach
untereinander aufteilen können das
müssen sie zur Kenntnis nehmen und sie
müssen auch zur Kenntnis nehmen dass man
die größte Krise unserer Zeit die
Klimakrise nur mit und eben nicht gegen
China bewältigen kann und wenn China zur
Klimakonferenz in Ägypten gerade mal
einen klimadiplomaten schickt und kein
Regierungsmitglied dann muss uns das
Sorge bereiten stattdessen greift Alena
baerbock sprachlich wieder mal die
Mottenkiste des Kalten Krieges und es
geht so nicht ich muss einfach sagen
außerdem
wissen sie auch siehe Trittin ganz genau
dass Deutschland aktuell fast
vollständig abhängig ist von China bei
der Lieferung von seltenen Erben Seltene
Erden auf die wir angewiesen sind um auf
erneuerbare Energien umstellen zu können
wenn also die Energiewende gelingen soll
dann sind wir auf Lieferungen aus dem
Land angewiesen dass einer baerbock als
systemischen Rivalen bezeichnet ja was
das denn ernsthaft ich meine ist in die
Bekämpfung des Klimawandels wirklich
weniger wichtig als die geopolitischen
Interessen der USA zu produzieren es
kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein
klar ist klar ist ein Wirtschaftskrieg
mit China hätte verheerende Folgen für
unser Land unzählige Arbeitsplätze wären
in Gefahr dass der falsche Kurs ein
falscher Kurs ist es aber auch kritische
Infrastruktur an Firmen zu verhökern wir
scheust das gerade beim Hamburger Hafen
auf den Weg gebracht hat nein kritische
Infrastruktur die gehört nicht an
chinesische Firmen verkauft sie gehört
überhaupt nicht verkauft sie gehört in
öffentliche Hand so ist es ich meine
lernen sie eigentlich gar nichts aus der
aktuellen Energiekrise sehen Sie nicht
dass die auch dadurch verschärft worden
ist dass die Gasspeicher in Deutschland
an die russische Firma gasfrauen
verkauft wurden das hatte damals
übrigens die Regierung bestehender SPD
und Union zu verantworten nichts vor
ungut Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Union ihre Krokodilstränen jetzt über
die Verkauf des Hamburger Hafens die
glaubt ihnen wirklich niemand
was wir brauchen ist eine realistische
und vernunftgeleitete China-Politik was
wir nicht brauchen das hat er Journalist
Luzern kürzlich im Freitag auf den Punkt
gebracht er sagte es habe wenig Sinn der
chinesische chinesischen
Wirtschaftspolitik mit einer ideologisch
und der fütterten Symbolpolitik begegnen
zu wollen das ist die Wahrheit danke
schön
vielen Dank
als nächster Redner das Wort der Kollege
Johannes Vogel FDP-Fraktion
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen bevor ich auf die diese
aktuelle Stunde beantragt haben eine
Fraktionen auf den Kollegen wadeful
eingehe
Frau Kollegin Mohammed Ali kann man
natürlich ganz vieles was sie hier
gesagt haben nicht so stehen lassen
also erstens scheinen sie mir doch
verblendet vor dem Hintergrund dass das
Regime in China in China unter season
Ping immer sozialistischer wird scheinen
sie mir doch ein Stück weit den Blick
darauf zu verlieren was dort passiert an
Unterdrückung an fortgesetzten
Menschenrechtsverletzungen und an
Totalüberwachung wie wir sie so noch
nicht überlegt haben erlebt haben
und das China ein systemischer Rivale
ist das hat hier nicht in der Debatte
irgendwann jemand gesagt sondern das
offizielle Position und Strategie der
Europäischen Union seit 2019 natürlich
ist China und das ist ja die
Herausforderung dieser systemwettbewerb
ganz neuer Art der ganz anders ist als
der Kalte Krieg aber genauso schwierig
und genauso tiefgreifen dass China eben
sowohl Partner bei globalen Fragen wie
dem Klimawandel ist und sein muss und
systemischer Rivale der ganz
grundlegende Werte von uns ablehnt und
sich fundamental unterscheidet das aber
keine neue Erkenntnis dieser Debatte
sondern Strategie der Europäischen Union
wo wir stehen ist die Frage welche ganz
konkrete politische Strategie folgt
eigentlich daraus das ist die
Herausforderung und Herr Kollege wadeful
dass sie das von der Bundesregierung
einfordern ist für die Opposition
legitim aber
nee ein bisschen
rutze hat es schon weil sie den Pin ja
nicht bei dem Parteikongress vor wenigen
Tagen an die Macht gekommen ist sondern
der Mann regiert seit 2012 und krempelt
das System der Volksrepublik China um
und seit 2012 hat übrigens auch die CDU
unter Angela Merkel hier regiert und ich
will nur mal ein paar Dinge erinnern
also sie mussten ja brutal dazu gedrängt
werden auch aus dem parlamentarischen
Raum dass sie in meinen Augen eine
Selbstverständlichkeit angehen nämlich
dass wir ein chinesisches Unternehmen
unter der Kontrolle der Kommunistischen
Partei wie Huawei raushalten müssen aus
dem Kern unseres Mobilfunknetzes musst
du Selbstverständlichkeit sein die von
ihnen getragene Vorgängerregierung
musste dazu getragen werden
die von ihnen getragene
Vorgängerregierung die wollte sogar noch
2020 nur aus pr-motiven kurz vor Ende
der EU-Ratspräsidentschaft das
investitionshandelsabkommen durch
Peitschen obwohl jeder wusste dass das
so nicht mehr in die Zeit passt das war
CDU-Politik lieber Kollege wadepool und
und dass sie den Hamburger Hafen
kritisch begleiten die Entscheidung über
den Hamburger Hafen die Debatte darüber
dass wertschätze ich denn werden wir
durchaus Debatten darüber gehabt aber
als Schleswig-Holsteiner kann ich nur
sagen dass ich das Interview ihres
CDU-Ministerpräsidenten da besonders
bemerkenswert fand der sagte ist doch
eine gute Nachricht das kostcomhang war
Hafen eingestiegen ist ich glaube dass
das Gegenteil einer guten Nachricht
liebe Kollegin und Kollegen
was will ich damit sagen
[Musik]
was will ich damit sagen vielleicht
sollten wir das parteipolitische
bodenturen lassen und hier gemeinsam die
Debatte darüber nutzen darüber
nachzudenken was eigentlich Gegenstand
dieser China-Politik sein muss denn ganz
offensichtlich muss sich die
China-Politik ändern weil sich die Natur
des chinesischen Regimes Grund gegen
geändert hat so und drei Gedanken von
meiner Seite weil diese Koalition und
diese Bundesregierung sich ja aufgemacht
haben eine neue china-strategie zu
schreiben und das ist absolut notwendig
erster Gedanke ganz offensichtlich
brauchen wir nicht nur einen
china-stresstest indem wir mal
definieren was ist eigentlich
sicherheitsrelevante Infrastruktur wo
wir gar keinen Einfluss der chinesischen
kommunistischen Partei und der von ihnen
kontrollierten Unternehmen haben wollen
was sind Bereiche wo unsere Abhängigkeit
von chinesischen Markt oder chinesischen
Lieferketten zu groß sind und was sind
Bereiche für die weder noch gilt und wo
wir freie handeln und Investitionen auf
gleicher Grundlage sicherstellen müssen
sich weniger abhängig vom chinesischen
Markt zu machen heißt dann aber auch
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
gerade jetzt eine freihandelsinitiative
brauchen weil das ja nur gelingen kann
wenn wir stärker Handel Investitionen
mit den marktwirtschaftlichen
Demokratien betreiben und deshalb bin
ich sehr froh dass wir sehr bald endlich
ceta ratifizieren werden als Auftakt für
diese Initiative dafür haben sie
übrigens auch nie die Kraft gefunden
zweitens ja es ist Teil
sicherheitspolitischer
Verantwortlichkeit dass uns nicht egal
sein kann
was sie erneut und nicht überraschen und
nicht neu mit Blick auf Taiwan
formuliert hat denn wir haben glaube ich
eins bei Putin hat jeder gelernt dass
man diese Autokraten in den
systemwettbewerben ernst und wörtlich
nehmen muss und deshalb müssen wir uns
auf den Fall einer chinesischen
militärischen Aggression in Taiwan
ernsthaft einstellen und drittens wer
ist eigentlich wir gehen Teil würde ich
wirklich gerne debattieren dass mein
letzter Satz lieber Herr Präsident wer
ist eigentlich wir weil Teil jeder neuen
china-strategie muss sein dass es nicht
bringt sie alleine zu entwickeln sondern
dass sie nur europäisch Sinn macht die
man auch bei den Häfen gesehen hat in
Wahrheit sogar nur transatlantisch und
in Kombination mit unseren wertepartnern
im Pazifik Sinn macht das muss
wesentlicher Bestandteil dieser
china-strategie sein vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
so vielen Dank aber auch das würde
wahrscheinlich bundestagsresidenten
machen wenn dann durch Redezeiten doch
enorm überzogen werden also im
ampelkoalitionsvertrag steht das so
ähnlich wie Johannes mich gerade gesagt
hat man strebe eine enge
transatlantische Abstimmung in der
China-Politik an und suche die
Zusammenarbeit mit Gleichgesinnten
Ländern um eben strategische
Abhängigkeiten zu reduzieren Jens Spahn
jetzt bis auf eine waren im Ausschuss
gegen jegliche Beteiligung am Hamburger
Hafen allein diese breite Mehrheit im
Ausschuss hier im Deutschen Bundestag
ist nicht Politik geworden Olaf Scholz
war als Handelsvertreter Hamburgs
unterwegs er hat aber nicht die
nationalen Interessen Deutschlands
vertreten sie haben sich als
Ampelkoalition hier gemacht Willen und
der brachialen Machtausübung des
Bundeskanzlers
und der Müller wenn sie regieren und die
Koalition ansprechen und 16 Jahre eins
kann ich Ihnen sagen regieren per
Richtlinienkompetenz nur um ein
Kernkraftwerk 86 Wochen länger laufen zu
lassen sich durchzusetzen brachial in
einer Blockade gegen 6 Bundesministerien
die gesagt haben diese Beteiligung am
Hamburger Hafen sollte es nicht geben
eine Außenministerin die aus Kasachstan
aus dem Ausland was er nicht mal wir als
Opposition machen würden aus dem Ausland
die eigene Regierung zu kritisieren eine
Außenministerin die aus dem Ausland
ihren Kanzler kritisiert ich kann nur
sagen die nächste Ausfahrt ist hier die
Vertrauensfrage so wie der Zustand in
ihrer Koalition ist und wie hier die
Dinge durchgesetzt werden das hätte es
diese brachiale Machtausübung aus dem
Kanzleramt diese Art auch europäisches
Porzellan zu zerschlagen dieses
Durcheinander hätte es in 16 Jahren
unionsgeführter Bundesregierung nie
gegeben da wurde vernünftig miteinander
umgegangen und da wurde sich abgestimmt
mit den europäischen Partnern
dabei gibt es dabei gibt es für die
künftige china-strategie eigentlich
einen großen Konsens hier in diesem Haus
China ist mit 1,4 Milliarden Menschen
ein wichtiger Handelspartner und wird es
auch bleiben deutschland ist und bleibt
Exportnationen mit der Welt verbunden
niemand möchte die Beziehungen zu China
abbrechen niemand hier möchte die
kappelig aber der Handel mit China ist
so weitgehend dass strategische
Abhängigkeiten drohen und das ist
übrigens der Grund warum wir das
Außenwirtschaftsrecht schon in den
letzten Jahren geändert haben nur auf
Basis dieser Änderungen kann doch die
Bundesregierung heute überhaupt
übernahmen untersagen und das gilt umso
mehr und das ist schon gesagt worden als
das China von heute ein anderes ist als
vor fünf oder vor zehn Jahren Autokraten
Lügen meist über Vergangenheit und
Gegenwart über die Zukunft sagen sie
nicht selten die Wahrheit da ist Ski
sehr transparent was eine gewaltsame
Einverleibung teilweise angeht was die
chinesische Rolle in der Welt angeht was
der strategische Schaffen von
Abhängigkeiten eben auch auf das
systematische aufkaufen etwa von
Hafeninfrastruktur angeht und deswegen
wären mögliche Prinzipien für eine
china-strategie zum Beispiel dass der
Reziprozität was ganz einfach heißt
solange sich kein deutsches Unternehmen
am Hafen in Shanghai beteiligen kann
sollte sich auch kein chinesisches am
Hamburger Hafen beteiligen können
einfaches Prinzip einfach umzusetzen
verstehen alle Partner oder wenn China
Stahl und Solarindustrie staatlich
stützt und Dumpingpreise auf der Welt
damit fördert dann kann es keinen freien
Marktzugang für China geben dann zum
Beispiel braucht es eben Zölle wir
müssen Abhängigkeiten Screen und schauen
wo sind Produkte leicht ersetzbar klar
sind Masken leichter ersetzbar als
Biotechnologie
stellen Sie sich eine Welt vor wo etwa
der Impfstoff nur in China und nicht
oder in Russland
und nicht etwa in der westlichen Welt
auch entwickelt worden wäre und wir
hätten alle in Peking betteln müssen um
Impfstoff zu kriegen es ist wichtig dass
wir screenen dass wir schauen wo könnten
Abhängigkeit entstehen etwa bei
Halbleitern bei Biotechnologien
militärtechnologien anderen Bereichen
und hier staatlich gegensteuern und es
gehört eben auch dazu zu diversifizieren
wir haben gerade vom Kollegen Vogel
gehört ceta würde bald ratifiziert uns
ist in der letzten Debatte hier erzählt
worden wir würden noch in diesem Herbst
wir sind auf dem großen Weg in den
Winter wir würden noch in diesem Herbst
hier das Handelsabkommen mit Kanada
ratifizieren nicht zuletzt um zu zeigen
wir wollen eine Handelspolitik wo wir
unabhängiger werden von China wenn das
so ist dann lassen Sie uns endlich über
ceta hier im Deutschen Bundestag
abstimmen und gemeinsam zustimmen
und China Politik beginnt zu Hause es
geht ja nicht nur allein um eine
china-strategie es geht doch um eine
deutschlandstrategie wenn wir souverän
sein wollen dann müssen wir auch
wirtschaftlich stark sein da müssen wir
eine Industriepolitik machen die dafür
sorgt dass unsere dass wir Industrie
Land bleiben gerade auch in dieser
Zeiten dass wir mithalten können das
gilt übrigens gerade mit Blick auf die
erneuerbaren Energien auch bei den
Windkraftanlagen sechs der zehn weltweit
größten Hersteller kommen aus China sie
kommen auf unseren Markt unsere können
nicht auf ihren Markt auch das kann so
nicht bleiben und deswegen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir können
China nicht ändern aber wir können an
uns arbeiten und unsere Stärken ausbauen
unser künftiger Wohlstand kann und darf
nicht von China abhängen dafür müssen
wir souveräner werden das ist im
Interesse unseres Landes fangen Sie
jetzt auch an so zu handeln sonst
scheitert ihre China Strategie schon
bevor sie überhaupt angefangen hat
hier der stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende für die Union und
das Thema Menschenrechte ist wenn man
mit China und über China spricht immer
ein Thema jetzt spricht der Sprecher für
Menschenrechte noch mal in die Tiere
Hilfe der SPD Frank Schwabe und Herren
Deutschlands strategische Souveränität
Stärken für eine neue china-strategie
das ist schön dass wir dieses hier das
diskutieren können weil es ja genau das
ist woran die Bundesregierung arbeitet
genau das ist der Titel dessen was wir
machen und ein kluger außenpolitischer
Akteur hat in den letzten Tagen gesagt
einige von ihnen waren dabei
erstens
Scholz ist deutlich kritischer
aufgetreten
in China als es Merkel jemals war
und zweitens
Merkel würde heute wahrscheinlich auch
kritischer auftreten als sie es damals
war als sie damals aufgetreten ist
insofern haben wir vielleicht alle
unsere Lerneffekte und ich will es noch
mal sagen weil sie das so ein bisschen
in Abrede stellen Frau Merkel war die
treibende Kraft eines EU China
Handelsabkommen sie war die kam eine
Kraft kann man alles nachlesen ich
zitiere im videomating mit Gigi Peng
sitzt die Kanzlerin ihren
wirtschaftsfreundlichen chinakurs fort
das war nicht 2014 sondern das stand in
der Süddeutschen Zeitung am 6 juli 2021
also vor gerade mal ein bisschen mehr
als einem Jahr und mich hat gerade ein
Kollege daran erinnert dass ich doch
vielleicht die Union vielleicht auch
Herrn sparen Herrn Wade voll und andere
persönlich daran erinnern kann wo sie
eigentlich waren bei der Debatte um den
Hafen in Piräus als wir Griechenland
dazu gedrängt haben und zwar zu 100
Prozent an China eine ganz wichtige
Infrastruktur in Europa wir waren da
übrigens auch irgendwo alle mit dabei
aber ich finde das falsch und ich finde
das könnten sie dann auch sagen also der
Anstoß zu der Debatte ist richtig aber
ich finde sie sollten deutlich machen
dass zum einen die Position innerhalb
der Parteien deutlich vielfältiger
verteilt sind auf den
Ministerpräsidenten von
Schleswig-Holstein ist schon hingewiesen
worden und ich finde es ist ein bisschen
seltsam mit welchem außenpolitischen
regurismus sie aus der Opposition
auftreten wir haben es bei Herrn Röttgen
und im Iran auch schon gesehen jetzt
machen sie es entsprechend bei China es
ist schon interessant welche Rolle die
Union dazu Zeit entsprechend einnimmt
und auch darauf ist hingewiesen worden
beim lieferkettengesetz und ich habe das
nun führen verhandelt haben sie ein
Jahrzehnt lang blockiert und versucht
das Ganze abzuschwängen es ist am Ende
gekommen aber im Grunde genommen gegen
ihren Widerstand und das wissen sie ganz
genau und das was wir damit erreicht
haben und das was wir jetzt von den
Unternehmen hören hat eine höhere
Bedeutung als das was wir drei
Jahrzehnte an Menschenrechtspolitik
gegenüber China diskutiert haben und das
ist gut und es ist gegen ihren
Widerstand durchgesetzt waren
der Zeitpunkt von Reisen im übrigen wird
von des Bundeskanzlers wird es
festgesetzt durch den Bundeskanzler und
nicht in jeder jedem Zeitpunkt steckt
auch eine Symbolik aber ich glaube wir
können doch alle gemeinsam mit aller
Ruhe feststellen dass dieser Besuch
erfolgreich war dass er notwendig war
dass es notwendig ist bei allen
Unterschieden die wir mit China haben
Russland zu isolieren oder zumindest
einzuheben und deswegen war es auch
richtig dass die Außenministerin in
Kasachstan war deswegen war es auch
richtig dass wir
regierungskonstellationen und
Konsultationen entsprechend mit Indien
hatten das war ein Erfolg das China
deutlich gemacht hat Atomwaffen mit
Atomwaffen zu drohen kann kein Teil von
Außenpolitik sein und es war auch doch
gut dass der Bundeskanzler die
Taiwan-Frage angesprochen hat und auch
menschenrechtlerinnen und
Menschenrechtler wie u weng Chang
entsprechend getroffen hat
wir sind uns hoffentlich oder die
meisten hier sind sich einig dass die
Menschenrechtslage in China verheerend
ist ob wir über tibetrehende Hongkong
oder anderes die uliguren Lage ingenjunk
ist verheerend wir haben eine Million
Menschen in sogenannten
Umerziehungslager wir haben
Zwangssterilisationen wir haben eine
permanente Überwachung wir haben die
Zerstörung von Religion und Kulturen das
ist eine Schande das ist uns als
Bundesregierung gemeinsam mit anderen
nicht gelungen ist das Thema im
unmenschenrechtsrat aufzusetzen weil
China ist verhindern konnte wir sehen
dass in Hongkong alle internationalen
Abkommen durch China gebrochen worden
sind dass die Medien gleichgeschaltet
sind und deswegen ist es gut und das
will ich auch an der Stelle sagen dass
wir fraktionsübergreifend ein
parlamentskreis Hongkong ins Leben
gerufen haben und ich will viele
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ermuntern da
auch entsprechend mit dazu zu kommen ich
will ein letztes nur sagen weil das
glaube ich auch zur china-strategie
gehört es ist eine außenpolitische
Strategie es ist aber auch eine
innenpolitische Strategie wir können
zulassen das betrifft übrigens nicht nur
China sondern auch andere Länder das
China versucht in Deutschland Druck auf
die Studenten auszuüben und dass sie
versuchen quasi staatliche überwachungs-
und Polizeistrukturen aufzubauen sondern
wir müssen mit aller Macht
außenpolitisch aber auch innenpolitisch
dem entgegenwirken vielen herzlichen
Dank
ja und während der Bundestag hier über
die neue china-strategie debattiert
melden die Nachrichtenagenturen dass
auch der US-Präsident Joe Biden sich mit
HE treffen wird in der kommenden Woche
und zwar am Rande des G20 Gipfels in
Indonesien
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin ich glaube
wir können zumindest ein Konsens in
dieser Debatte finden wir müssen die
Europäische Union als handlungsakteur in
diesem politischen Umfeld Stärken
wirtschaftlich und strategisch dass es
essentiell für jede china-strategie
morgen reise ich zusammen mit dem
Wirtschaftsminister und anderen
Parlamentariern nach Singapur zur Asia
und pazifik-konferenz der deutschen
Wirtschaft und auch dort wird natürlich
der weiße Elefant im Raum China sein
wenn man sich mal die
handelsverpflichtung und dieser Welt
anschaut ist China nicht nur der größte
Handelspartner faktisch alle asiatischen
Staaten übrigens im Jahr 2050 wird 50
Prozent des weltbruttosozialprodukts in
Asien bestimmt sondern auch fast alle
afrikanischen Staaten und auch eines
Teils Südamerikas und auch unser größte
Handelspartner ist China
china macht gleichzeitig 33 Prozent der
weltweiten CO2-Emissionen aus baut
gleichzeitig die Kohlekraft aus und ist
weltgrößter Investor in der erneuerbaren
Energien
china hat über 80% Anteil an der
weltweiten Produktion an
Photovoltaikanlagen und einen Anteil an
73% an der Herstellung von
Batteriezellen das sind erstmal Trends
die so bestehen und der Kampf gegen die
Klimakrise das wissen wir alle wird ohne
China auch nicht funktionieren auf der
anderen Seite heißt das aber auch für
uns dass wir wirtschaftliche
Abhängigkeiten von China reduzieren
müssen denn die Abhängigkeiten sind
heute sehr groß und nach der Erfahrung
mit Russland kann man sicherlich sich
nicht hinstellen und sagen wir können
darauf vertrauen dass wir weiter ein
friedliches China vorfinden werden es
ist alles möglich leider alles möglich
mit diesem China auch ein Angriff auf
Taiwan deswegen müssen wir jetzt
Umsteuern eine neue Strategie auf dem
Weg bringen
27 nicht einzelne Branchen sind ja auch
sehr stark exponiert in China
beispielsweise die Automobilindustrie VW
verkauft über 40 Prozent seiner
Fahrzeuge dort
unsere Wirtschaft ist angewiesen auf
kritische Rohstoffe Seltene Erden das
sind Anteile von bis zu 90 Prozent in
Einzelbereichen hat es bereits genannt
und deswegen ist es so notwendig und
richtig und ich bin auch dankbar für die
Debatte heute dass die Bundesregierung
die Koalition eine neue china-strategie
auf den Weg bringt die unsere
wirtschaftliche Abhängigkeit Schritt für
Schritt befördert
ich nenne ein paar Beispiele die
kritische Infrastruktur ist ein Beispiel
das genannt wurde der Fall von Costco es
ist gut dass wir in den Gesprächen zu
der Lösung gekommen sind dass es eine
finanzielle aber keine strategische
Beteiligung an Koske gibt und es gut
dass wir das herbeigeführt haben
es ist auch gut dass wir jetzt die
Diskussion in der Koalition haben das
ausländische Investitionen in kritische
Infrastrukturen systematischer und
restriktiver geprüft werden ich denke
dass es notwendig und wir brauchen auch
eine europäische Strategie im Umgang mit
ausländischen Investitionen
zweites Beispiel sind die kritischen
Technologien und Produktionskapazitäten
das Beispiel elmos dass wir auch diese
Tage hatten wir haben ja eine ganze
Reihe von prüferverfahren von
chinesischen Direktinvestitionen in
Deutschland die Halbleiterindustrie ist
natürlich essentiell taiwan ist da der
Weltmarktführer sollte es zu einer
Konfrontation China Taiwan kommen wird
die gesamte Weltwirtschaft
beeinträchtigt werden was kann die
Konsequenz sein doch nur dass wir als
Deutschlands Europäische Union die
Kapazitäten selber Stärken deswegen sind
solche Investitionen in Magdeburg mit
Intel 23 Milliarden Euro am Standort
wichtig und das müssen wir weiter
voranbringen
das Thema Rohstoffe es ist gut dass die
Bundesumweltministerin jetzt ein
kreislaufwirtschaftskonzept auf dem Weg
bringt und dass wir einen rohrmaterials
Act im kritischen Bereich jetzt auch auf
den Weg bringen Brand der Europäischen
Union wir sind ein Kontinent mit wenig
eigenen Ressourcen deswegen ist
nachhaltigkeitssystemability erneuerbare
Energien das ist der Weg in die
Unabhängigkeit und den müssen wir
entschlossen beschreiten und da
investieren dass es Priorität haben
Nummer eins in den nächsten Jahren
und der sparen sie hat uns auch
angesprochen die Diversifizierung im
Außenhandel das ist absolut auch ziel
der Gespräche den nächsten Monaten und
Jahren wir werden keine leichten
Gespräche haben weil die Partner auch
nicht immer leicht sind aber natürlich
kommt es darauf an dass wir auf der
einen Seite Freihandelsabkommen jetzt
auch finden mit fairen sozialen
ökologischen und auch
menschenrechtlichen Standards denn wir
müssen auch ein level playing viel
schaffen für die neue Wirtschaft und auf
der anderen Seite
Investitionsförderung auch neu
ausrichten ich glaube das
Risikomanagement kann heute nicht mehr
sein dass die Unternehmen in China von
uns erwarten dass wir alles absichern
wenn sie in kritische Felder gehen da
muss auch ein Stück weit mehr
Eigenverantwortung der deutschen
Wirtschaft wieder geschaffen werden es
muss klar sein dass Unternehmen ihr
Risiko in China selbst tragen müssen
und zum Schluss China ist eine
Autokratie und ein geopolitischer Rivale
im Wettstreit mit dem demokratischen
Westen aber in der komplizierten Welt
ist es eben auch so dass es ein
wirtschaftlicher Partner ist und
Gespräche Kooperation im Bereich der
Forschung des Klimaschutzes bei all den
Schwierigkeiten und den öko-politik in
China macht es ja nicht gerade leicht
Gespräche gerade zu führen wenn ein Land
sich komplett abschottet was er auch zu
Aggressivität zu neuer
stimmungsveränderung geführt hat
trotzdem bleibt das notwendig auch diese
Gespräche weiterzuführen aber
entscheidend ist immer dass wir unsere
eigene Stärke definieren wirtschaftliche
Souveränität wiederherstellen ob im
Bereich der Energiepolitik und in
wirtschaftlichen Verhältnis zu China
daran müssen wir entschlossen Arbeiten
ich danke
sagt Dieter Janecek hier für die grüne
Fraktion der Sprecher für
Wirtschaftspolitik und diese Funktion
nämlich wirtschaftspolitischer Sprecher
hat der nächste hier am Rednerpult
Reinhard Hupen für die Liberalen inne
ja frau Präsidentin meine Damen und
Herren eine solche Debatte als aktuelle
Stunde
kann ja auch manchmal Überraschungen mit
sich bringen und neue Erkenntnisse aber
so richtig viel neue Erkenntnisse und
Überraschungen hat es für mich
eigentlich bei den Beiträgen der Union
noch nicht gegeben sie haben viele Dinge
vollkommen richtig beschrieben
aber die meisten davon sind ja nicht neu
das einzige was sie anführen können neu
war der Parteitag der KP vor einigen
Wochen und der Besuch
von Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz und ich
möchte Ihnen mal auch ein Feedback aus
der deutschen Wirtschaft dazu geben das
gesagt worden es war sehr richtig dass
der Bundeskanzler in China war und
alleine alleine die Bemerkung
dass man auf Atomwaffen im Krieg
zwischen Russland und der Ukraine
verzichten soll das war die Meinung aus
der Wirtschaft hat gesagt allein dafür
hat sich die Reise gelohnt
und meine Damen und Herren dem stimme
ich auch zu denn
Deeskalation in der aktuellen Situation
ist sicherlich nicht unwichtig
und wenn ich dann die Beiträge hier in
der Debatte führe müssen wir das doch
weiterentwickeln was sind wir denn
bereit zu tun um die Dinge die hier
gefordert worden sind auch wirklich zu
erreichen
und da möchte ich anschließend an den
Kollegen
die Bundesregierung
arbeitet an einer neuen china-strategie
und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher Kollege
Spahn auch die wird noch im Herbst
kommen und der Herbst dauert bis zum 21
Dezember das vielleicht auch noch zur
Aufklärung und meine Damen und Herren
wir sind weiterhin aktiv im Gespräch
was Handelsverträge angeht und es
betrifft nicht nur ceta sie formulieren
das ja sehr gerne ich nehme das immer
wieder auch gerne auf wir sind in
Gesprächen sehr weit mit Chile wir sind
sehr weit mit Mexiko ich glaube die
Entscheidung ist brasilianischen
souverän hat auch Optionen eröffnet zum
Thema Merkur Suhr und dann müssen wir
natürlich auch entsprechend entschieden
handeln und sozusagen den Deckel drauf
machen denn eins kann auch nicht sein
meine Damen und Herren wir können hier
nicht wohlfeile Debatten im Hohen Hause
führen und am Ende ist darauf ankommen
lassen dass die deutsche Wirtschaft die
europäische Wirtschaft in China dann
alleine dasteht und ja es ist
angesprochen worden
es ist angesprochen worden wie reagieren
wir denn wir hatten noch Angst davor
dass bei dem Angriff auf die Ukraine
unter Umständen
unterhalb des Radars China auch in
Taiwan angreifen
inwieweit sind wir darauf vorbereitet
ich glaube
die bessere Ausrüstung der Bundeswehr
auch der Einsatz der Luftwaffe
in Südostasien hat gezeigt dass wir da
sicherlich nicht
kanodenbodenpolitik betreiben wollen
aber dass unsere Freunde und Partner in
diesem Raum auch auf unsere
Unterstützung setzen können und
und meine Damen und Herren wir haben es
im Koalitionsvertrag festgelegt wir
arbeiten heftig dran man kann sich nicht
nur darüber beklagen dass Seltene Erden
zum Beispiel in einer großen Menge aus
China kommen dann müssen wir halt nach
Alternativen suchen und wir haben unter
Umständen im Erzgebirge Optionen Seltene
Erden auch in Deutschland zu heben dann
müssen wir eben die Rahmenbedingungen
entsprechend setzen und das gibt der
Koalitionsvertrag her meine Damen und
Herren und deswegen bin ich auch da der
Meinung ja wir müssen uns mit der
Problematik auseinandersetzen ja wir
müssen differenzieren unsere
verkaufsmärkte und unsere Einkaufsmärkte
aber da hilft es eben nicht nur hier
wohlfeile Anträge zu stellen sondern
dass in konkrete Politik umzusetzen und
dazu sind wir entschlossener sparen wie
gesagt Herbst sie haben mein Wort und
eine letzte politische Bemerkung
eine letzte politische Bemerkung und die
fehlt auf uns ich glaube alle zurück
wir müssen in Deutschland lernen was
unsere
spezifischen Interessen sind das müssen
wir gemeinsam mit unseren europäischen
Partnern entwickeln und dann müssen wir
uns auch in Anführungszeichen trauen an
manchen Stellen in unserer Politik auch
wirklich die Interessen Europas und
Deutschlands robust zu vertreten und
dort habe ich auch einen gewissen
Optimismus vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
Reinhard Hupen war das für die FDP ja es
geht ja nicht nur um solche besonderen
Dinge wie die Seltenen Erden sondern
wenn man mal auf China als
Handelspartner schaut dass Statistische
Bundesamt hatte mitgeteilt dass die
Volksrepublik China im Jahr 2021 zum
sechsten Mal in Folge der wichtigste
Handelspartner Deutschlands war
der Bundeskanzler stellt nach seiner
Reise Verlässlichkeit und Vertrauen fest
die das Fundament der
deutsch-chinesischen Beziehungen bilden
ganz abgesehen davon was unsere Partner
in der EU und in USA wohl dabei gedacht
haben ich glaube nicht dass das
angemessene Begriffe sind wenn wir über
ein Treffen mit einem Diktator sprechen
Vertrauen bei illegalen chinesischen
Polizeistationen in unserem Land bei
aggressiven Auftreten im Südchinesischen
Meer und vor allem bei gröbsten
Menschenrechtsverletzungen gegen die
rekurische Minderheit
Verlässlichkeit wenn in unseren
Unternehmen nach wie vor geistiges
Eigentum gestohlen wird wenn wir nach
wie vor keine kleinen Bedingungen auf
dem chinesischen Markt haben und wenn
bewusst weiter
asymmetrische Abhängigkeiten geschaffen
sind kurzum China unter den Präsidenten
hier ist kein verlässlicher Partner
vertrauen Verlässlichkeit diese Begriffe
sind hier fehl am Platz
an Putin sehen wir dass wir Autokraten
und Diktatoren bei wortnehmen müssen und
deshalb und ich glaube das sind wir uns
hier auch einig in der Debatte muss sich
die Politik gegenüber China verändern
die Vorzeichen haben sich geändert
deswegen ist es gut dass das Auswärtige
Amt eine china-strategie entwickeln will
ich bin aber wirklich gespannt auf das
Ergebnis denn bisher hat die Koalition
nicht mit Einigkeit in außenpolitischen
Fragen geglänzt ob das Unterstützung der
Ukraine ist ob das
der Hamburger Hafen ist oder ob das die
China-Reise ist wo die Außenministerin
Ratschläge aus der Ferne ans
Bundeskanzleramt schickt ich bin auch
gespannt wenn es an die Umsetzung so
einer Strategie gibt weil es auswärtige
am kann natürlich viel zu Papier bringen
wenn am Schluss das Kanzleramt und
andere das vielleicht ignorieren dann
ist die Strategie das Papier nicht wert
auf dem sie geschrieben wird Beispiele
wie brachial das Kanzleramt ihre
Position durchdrückt gab es ja in der
jüngeren Vergangenheit bereits zu
beobachten
und
diese Uneinigkeit der Ampel Außenpolitik
ist extrem problematisch weil die
Aufgabe einer kinderstrategie ist es
natürlich auch dass das europaweit und
idealerweise auch mit unseren
transatlantischen Partnern abgestimmt
wird und natürlich bleibt China trotz
alle mein wichtiger Partner unserer
Wirtschaft bei gleichzeitiger
systemischer Rivalität aber diese
Uneinigkeit in der Regierung die sorgt
auch für große Verunsicherungen der
Wirtschaft was wir jetzt brauchen sind
echte Alternativen neue Märkte
Handelsabkommen ich sagte einfach nur
endlich machen an uns wird es dich
liegen wir haben es schon lange bei ceta
zumindest eingebracht und warten da
endlich auf die Umsetzung und sind
gespannt wie es hier versprochen wurde
ob es dann in der nächsten Zeit auch
klappt wir brauchen eine neue Handels-
und Rohstoffstrategie und wir müssen vor
allem unsere wirtschaftliche
Abhängigkeiten einem Stresstest
unterziehen so dass am Schluss eben auch
für unsere Unternehmen eine klare
Orientierung und klare Rahmenbedingungen
stehen
wir müssen uns auch bewusst sein meine
Damen und Herren das zum Beispiel durch
Aktionen wie der Verkauf von Anteilen am
Hamburger Hafen auch unsere
Glaubwürdigkeit leidet weil wir sind
unterwegs in Afrika in Südamerika und
waren in vorchinesischer Abhängigkeit
und diese Partner sagen dann was bringen
wir eure Warnungen wenn ihr gleichzeitig
selber euch in diese Abhängigkeit begibt
wenn ihr gleichzeitig selber hier auch
China Zutritt zu strategischer und zu
wichtiger Infrastruktur zulässt
und meine Damen und Herren ich glaube
dass man auch sagen kann Repression im
Inneren führt irgendwann immer zu
Aggression nach außen das muss ich ja
als erstblütiger einfach darstellen und
deshalb ist es so wichtig dass wir hier
einen klaren Kurs brauchen einen klaren
Kurs in unserer Politik zu China mit
China und der ist bei dieser Regierung
bisher noch nicht sichtbar wir warten
auf eine klare Linie herzlichen Dank
Thomas erndl der Sprecher der CSU
Landesgruppe für internationales und
Sicherheit und
einen Redner haben wir jetzt noch in
dieser Debatte in dieser aktuellen
Stunde Esra Limbacher für die SPD
Präsidentin liebe Kollegen und Kollegen
Michael Müller und Frank Schwabe haben
dankenswerterweise schon viele und
wichtige Punkte in Bezug auf
Menschenrechte und Pressefreiheit sowohl
die sowie die außenpolitischen
Sichtweisen in Bezug auf China hier
dargelegt erlauben Sie mir daher auf
wirtschaftspolitische Aspekte einer
china-strategie die wir dringend
brauchen und da sind wir uns glaube ich
alle einig dass wir darauf mal schauen
ich habe mir die Debatte heute genau
angehört und auch das was in den
vergangenen Tagen so veröffentlicht
wurden Herr wadenful Herr Spahn ich muss
ehrlich sagen bin ein bisschen
verunsichert und irritiert wenn sogar
besorgt was hat man dort gelesen der
Bundeskanzler müsse seine China-Reise
Absagen Investitionen auch deutscher
Firmen dürfen auf keinen Fall erfolgen
die deutsche Wirtschaft soll sich von
der chinesischen Wirtschaft entkoppeln
sozusagen statt der märkischen Lösung
Wandel durch Handel Wandel durch keinen
Handel liebe Kollegen und Kollegen das
ist doch Wahnsinn Protektionismus
Abschottung und Entkopplung das kann
nicht unsere Antwort auf die Fragen
dieser Zeit sein liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
ich frage mich ernsthaft wenn wir auch
wirtschaftspolitisch darüber diskutieren
haben sie in letzter Zeit eigentlich mal
mit Betriebsräten mit Angestellten in
der deutschen Industrie gesprochen haben
sie das mir scheint das es nicht der
Fall
corona-pandemie der völkerrechtliche
widrige Angriffskrieg Putins
Energiekrise
Fachkräftemangel die Liste ist immer
weiter fortsetzbar und sie wollen hier
neue Krise einen neuen Handelskonflikt
herbeirreden dass es unverantwortlich
und findet nicht unsere Zustimmung
[Applaus]
das Negativbeispiel USA zeigt doch wie
es momentan nicht geht
protektionistische Subventionswettlauf
ist eben keine Antwort auf die
Herausforderung in unserer Zeit hier
geht es nicht um irgendwas sondern auch
um unseren Wirtschaftsstandort und um
Arbeitsplätze hier vor Ort ich komme aus
dem Saarland wissen sie und da ist
Transformation die Herausforderung den
wir gegenüberstehen ich schaue sie an
weil sie das gesagt haben ist die
Herausforderung wir kämpfen da um jeden
Arbeitsplatz in der Industrie und die
die Firmen die dort investieren die
kommen weder aus Wolfsburg die kommen
nicht aus der EU die kommen nicht aus
der USA sondern eben aus China und genau
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir uns
nicht abschotten sondern offen sind für
Handel auch mit China genau das muss
unsere Strategie sein und wenn wir
wirtschaftspolitisch auf diese Frage
wird Strategie und wirtschaftspolitische
Strate mit China schauen dann ist auch
immer eine Frage können wir da eine
Doppelstrategie draus machen ich finde
das muss eine Doppelstrategie sein
erstens Handel mit China ausbauen
zweitens
diversifizieren und einseitige
Abhängigkeiten
beenden ich glaube es ist ein Irrglaube
das Handel per se zur Abhängigkeit führt
und ich finde das Beweis hat ein
Institut angeführt dass jetzt keine
Vorfeldorganisation der SPD ist nämlich
das Ifo-Institut das hat untersucht den
Warenverkehr zwischen Deutschland und
China und das Ergebnis war bei den
meisten Produkten die die EU aus der
Volksrepublik bezieht gibt es
Alternativen auf dieser Welt und
gleichzeitig ist China auf den
europäischen Absatzmarkt angewiesen das
zeigt eins es herrscht zwischen den
beiden handelsblöcken ein Gleichgewicht
das ein selbstbewusstes Auftreten
Deutschlands wirklich ermöglicht und das
ist auch nötig in so einer Doppel geht
dann natürlich müssen wir auch auf die
Probleme schauen das sind die
einseitigen Abhängigkeiten in der
Handelsbeziehung die ist eben nicht
geben darf genau daran muss gearbeitet
werden Teil einer china-strategie muss
also immer sein dass wir insbesondere
bei Rohstoffen und wichtigen
Technologien diversifizieren und nicht
einseitig abhängig machen also
Doppelstrategie Abhängigkeiten abbauen
Handel aufbauen Arbeitsplätze in unserem
Land sichern liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das kann ein Ansatz für unser
Land sein und Herr wadenpfuhl vielleicht
zum Abschluss erlauben Sie mir noch ein
Kommentar wie alle können uns noch ganz
gut erinnern wie auch sie wie ich finde
gedankenlos in Zusammenhang mit dem
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg in
der Ukraine agiert haben
ich hoffe und man kann nur hoffen
dass sie die Frage
auch nicht dass sie diese Art und Weise
nicht auf die taiwane Frage
transferieren das hätte nämlich wahrlich
schwere erfolgen für unser Land liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir brauchen
klare Strategien und kein Populismus das
ist die Zeichen der Zeit vielen Dank
ich schließe die aktuelle